one of my favorite lines in this movie
is a certain line involving a door
there's a door in my way you approach
all doors now and say that and while
you're doing that a million times over
on set is it funny that was never shot
to be funny that was shot to be like
I'll be back or like a kick-ass line I
think what makes it funny in watching
the movie again and again is Travis was
very kind enough to sprinkle some comedy
in there early you get a good moment of
comedy in the conference room some when
you when you initially meet agent burns
you get some comedy so you know this guy
has a little bit of a dynamic
personality
we shot agent burns originally down the
barrel serious but I think it's those
moments that you laugh which when the
guy says what's supposed to be an 80s
badass line because now you feel more
connected to him literally is a joke so
I like that and I like that it's taken
as a joke because that is this guy like
okay just do it cuz it's a blow the door
off I can't wait until other people get
to see this movie so when I say there's
a door in my way people don't look at me
like I'm weird anymore I'm gonna borrow
that one it really is a great one-liner
speaking of the humor in this movie too
is one of the greatest things about your
character is that he kind of says what
the audience is thinking which i think
is a really nice touch here especially
when we've seen so many Transformers
movies before so did you guys get to
come up with any of that on the spot we
had great conversations about what we
thought agent burns was and Travis had a
clear-cut vision and then through strict
preparedness and being able to film what
we wanted - quite early drafts would
come out all right
go ahead and take one for you and that
would be you know I would definitely be
selfish enough to take one for me
expecting none of it to make the movie
but I think over the course
Travis being so astute watching some of
those outtakes being like okay that's
not gonna make it but what he's saying
we can do something with that and would
come back may I just try this instead
and that's when you have like guys there
call Decepticons like come on like those
moments of
frankness and it is because Burns sees
all of them as a threat where he can hit
the details over the head and it's cool
because you said we're saying what the
fans want to but here you have a scene
of a guy saying they're pretty much bad
and everybody's like yeah but then the
argument is but the Russians will get
them so go back in the time machine to
the height of the Cold War that
supersedes everything so it also
explains like hitting the nail on the
head like yeah they're bad
none of the Russians look at all don't
forget the bad stuff don't let the
Russians get them so it it also covers
up a possible a story point that's right
there that needs to be addressed but
also is superseded by a more important
cause between this and blockers you have
a year here that just really excites me
because I feel like it's the year of an
entertaining movie plus we're getting
this pure entertainment the cinematic
experience that has something more to it
so can you talk about so when we you
know oftentimes you use the word
franchise and that comes with
expectations of being grandiose the
settings of grandiose what what stunts
are they going to do next
I come from a world of physical
storytelling and I know that if you
continue to raise the bar on what will
you do next
you eventually do everything everything
you're capable of action for the sake of
action is no good it's that's a means to
end I think when you care about someone
you want to root for them and I have a
fight with bumblebee in this movie that
is very short and it should be and it's
purposeful and it's amazing it's a
wonderful scene because I'm invested in
both being a root inform and those are
the most important things and that's
that's what's special about this movie
it doesn't feel like an installment it
feels like a tale of friendship
you